son skill I look for a lot more lately
is people's writing skills because so
much now is done online you know it used
to be there with so many more calls made
if someone cannot communicate well
concisely funny witty but clear short in
emails like so much interaction of
business happens in emails or you know
understanding how to present themselves
in emails and Twitter and fitness is a
whole language that at this point that's
really crucial so after I be with them
if I really like them I will then follow
up with like some email tests we're in
this situation you have to write me
about this and because it's just it's
it's hard to train and I have trained
people in it but communicating such an
important skill and if they're
communicating on behalf of our film
studio about X wine you know it's just
so much easier if they have a good sense
about it
you